[ZH] 我們邀請的也是Tills北區臨床總監
[ZH] Joe Davis 跟我們分享
[ZH] 他在臨床上的實務經驗
[ZH] 大家如果有任何在聽獎的過程裡面
[ZH] 想要更進一步瞭解人
[ZH] 都還是可以在QRQ的連結上
[ZH] 將你的問題發到我們的研究表彈裡面
[ZH] 接下來我們是不是就歡迎
[ZH] Joe Davis 為我們開啟下一個獎題
[EN]  Although we come from different countries and different healthcare systems,
[EN]  adolescents and families come to us and need help.
[EN]  We want to reduce suffering,
[EN]  and we want to help young people feel healthier and more meaningful lives.
[ZH] 發生健康、更重要的生活
[ZH] 大家早安
[ZH] 今天很榮幸可以跟大家回到見面
[ZH] 首先我要感謝主辦單位的邀請
[ZH] 雖然我們來自不同的國家
[ZH] 還有醫療體系
[ZH] 但我相信我們都用同樣的使命
[ZH] 我們都渴望可以去了解和幫助
[ZH] 來找我們的青少年還有家庭
[ZH] 我們也希望可以陪伴這些年輕人
[ZH] 經歷更健康專業的人生
[EN]  most of the young people we serve have not experienced just one challenge
[EN]  they often present depression adhd anxiety trauma substance use learning disorders
[EN]  and or significant family conflicts by the time they arrive many of them have already worked with
[EN]  several therapists psychiatrists schools or treatment programs as clinicians our responsibility
[ZH] 作為醫師,我們的責任是不只是提供醫療,而我們的第一責任是理解。
[ZH] 這引起一個問題,我希望大家今天要考慮一下。
[ZH] 在過去的12年,我一直在Tilos,就是一家青少年全人全日寫的照顧機構工作
[ZH] 那我們服務的大多數青少年,他們面臨的謀往不是單一的挑戰
[ZH] 他們來找我們的時候,常常不只是有ADHD、憂鬱、焦慮、創傷、甚至有固執、啟用、學習障礙、還有嚴重的家庭充分等多重問題就在一起
[ZH] 那他來我們這個機構前
[ZH] 許多孩子甚至已經看過很多微心理治療師
[ZH] 精神醫生
[ZH] 也經歷過很多學校來不同單位的治療計畫
[ZH] 那身為一個臨床的專業人員
[ZH] 我認為我們的責任不僅是提供治療
[ZH] 我們的首要責任是去理解
[ZH] 所以這個帶出了我今天希望大家一起
[ZH] 可以來共同思考的問題
[ZH] 就是要成為一名卓越的臨床專業人員
[ZH] 真正的意涵是甚麼
[ZH] 如果我們問100醫生這些問題,我們可能會收到100不同的答案。
[ZH] 有些可能說是知識,有些可能說是經驗。
[ZH] 有些會表示技術或技術的一個特別模式。
[ZH] 這些都是重要的,但我會推薦一些不同的。
[ZH] 醫生的技術會開始早前治療。
[ZH] 它開始是理解。
[ZH] 那如果你問100位臨床工作者
[ZH] 就是什麼樣的一個臨床專業人員
[ZH] 是一個卓越的專業人員
[ZH] 大概會有一百種不同版本的答案
[ZH] 有些人可能認為重要的是專業知識
[ZH] 有些人說是臨床經驗
[ZH] 有些人說是對於某種特定治療
[ZH] 某次的精通掌握
[ZH] 這些都很重要
[ZH] 但是呢我會覺得核心
[ZH] 其實存在於更根本的事物
[ZH] 就是治療開始之前就發生了
[ZH] 就是理解這件事情
[ZH] 謝謝
[ZH] 一段時間影響了我的醫生思維是,當資訊欠缺乏,所有選擇都是避免的。
[ZH] 多年來深深影響我在臨床思維的一句話是,如果你資訊不重組的時候,所有的選擇都是充滿風險。
[ZH] 那我相信這句話會適用於我們身為心理健康專業人員做出的每一個決定
[ZH] 當我們缺乏關鍵資訊的話,我們的治療決策就會失去精準度。
[ZH] 我們給出去的建議就無法真正做到個別化。
[ZH] 我們的介入措施就會更加依賴主觀的假設。
[ZH] 這些假設有些是正確的,有些卻是錯誤的。
[ZH] 我們當醫生的責任責任是減少不確實力,
[ZH] 之前決定要去接觸。
[ZH] 那是為了討論或討論和討論和討論是很重要的。
[ZH] 我常常提到我們的討論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論論
[ZH] 我常常提醒我們的醫院, 診施並不只是我們完成任務, 診施是一種詢問的。
[ZH] 每個療程、每個家庭、每個交通、每個交通、每個交通、 每個交通、每個交通、 加上醫院的照片, 加上醫院的照片, 加上醫院的照片。
[ZH] 如何介入之前呢
[ZH] 然後進口的降低確定性
[ZH] 那這就是為什麼
[ZH] 呃深思熟悅的觀察
[ZH] 還有全方位的螢幕
[ZH] 是非常重要的
[ZH] 那我會常提醒我們的這個
[ZH] 臨床團隊
[ZH] 螢幕不是隻有
[ZH] 克蘭剛進案提示的這個表格而已
[ZH] 它是一段動態的
[ZH] 它是持續的
[ZH] 所以每一次心理治療的面談
[ZH] 每一次家庭會議
[ZH] 還有呢
[ZH] 與生活團隊每一次的交流
[ZH] 還有與青少年的每次互動
[ZH] 其實都是在為整理的臨床全貌增添的一個室施就可靠的
[ZH] 那我們理解就越完整
[ZH] 我們就越有把握
[ZH] 我可以把擬定的這個治療計劃是在解決問題的根本成因
[ZH] 而不是對於表面的症狀去做出一些很被動很標準的反應
[EN*]  Rather, it is a practical framework that helps our clinicians to organize their thinking during the assessment and the treatment plan.
[ZH] 這個是我們KELOS 機構的臨床評估論
[ZH] 那它的目的不是要去取代已經建立的心理血論
[ZH] 或是實證治療的模式
[ZH] 你可以把它當作是一個實物的架構
[ZH] 那它存在的目的是要協助我們的臨床人員
[ZH] 在評估還有擬定治療計劃的時候
[ZH] 幫助你去釐清你的思維
[ZH] 中間的核心是青少年個案本人
[EN*]  So you can see the center in the middle of this slide is the middle of青少年.
[EN*]  The circle around this slide is the six values.
[EN*]  The first thing is the body.
[EN*]  Hard wiring.
[EN*]  The second thing is the brain.
[EN*]  Learned behaviors.
[EN*]  Personality and characteristic patterns.
[EN*]  Trauma.
[EN*]  And environmental factors.
[EN*]  Every adolescent is influenced by all six domains, the question is never whether a domain exists, the question is how much that domain contributes to the adolescent from the presentation.
[EN*]  For one adolescent, biology might be the primary driver, for another, trauma, for another executive functioning, for another chronic family disorder.
[EN*]  Every child has a lot of impact on the 6th grade. So we are not asking the question of which child is affected by this child, but the child has a lot of impact on the child. So, for example, the child is the most important thing to do. So, for example, the child is the most important thing to do.
[ZH] 所以我們要問的問題並不是哪一個領域是有影響到這個孩子的
[ZH] 而是哪一個領域對於這個青少女當前的困境
[ZH] 是造成了多大程度最大程度的影響
[ZH] 所以對某些孩子來說
[ZH] 他的生理因素可能是最主要的驅動因素
[ZH] 另外一個孩子來說
[ZH] 他的關鍵可能在於他有創傷
[ZH] 對另外一個孩子來說
[ZH] 可能是執行功能障礙
[ZH] 或是他有一個長期沒有解決的家庭衝突
[EN*]  and it's not to give the answer to all the questions.
[EN*]  One reason I like this framework is because it encourages humility.
[EN]  It reminds us that our first explanation is not always the correct explanation.
[EN]  It encourages curiosity, collaboration, and continued assessment
[EN]  until we have a more complete understanding of the adolescent sitting in front of us.
[EN]  We call this being a humble detective.
[EN]  I believe those qualities, curiosity, humility, and thoughtful assessment are hallmarks to clinical excellence.
[ZH] 他會提醒我們說你第一時間冒出來的這個其實並不是未必正確的
[ZH] 他會鼓勵我們要保持好奇心
[ZH] 然後要跨專業的合作還有持續評估
[ZH] 直到我們對一點錢就會青少年有更完整的理解
[ZH] 所以我會形容我們要當一個謙虛的偵探
[ZH] 我會相信當一個謙虛偵探需要具備這些特質
[ZH] 好奇心謙虛還有深思熟慮的理由
[ZH] 那這就是我認為什麼可以叫做一個卓越的理由
[ZH] 我們現在有架構,我們就要帶大家來醫學探討這六個領域。
[ZH] 最初的核心提問,究竟是哪些因素的交織組合最能夠解釋我眼前這位青少林目前的適應,還有運作功能水準,那這個提問會導致我們接下來的導論。
[ZH] 臨床卓越人員,大家可能會想到這個人有豐富的資歷啊,有專業證照等等,那這些不然很重要,但是我相信臨床卓越的定義其實比較是取決於我們如何去思考,而不是我們知道什麼。
[ZH] 所以對我來說,臨床卓越表現就是要可以精準去理解個案,為什麼會陷入這樣的困境,然後精準去鎖定為什麼導致它功能失調,背後真正的原因是什麼?
[ZH] 請注意我一開始並不是從治療開始談,我是一直強調到理解,因為治療成效的好壞其實是取決於背後的理解有多順候。
[ZH] 如果我們的離脊是殘缺不全的話,我們的治療計畫也註定會是殘缺不全的。
[ZH] 我回顧我的職業生涯中對我造成有深刻影響啟發的臨床人員的學長前輩,
[EN*]  Within that complete comprehensive assessment, they resist the temptation to jump to conclusions
[EN*]  and instead gather information from multiple sources before making important clinical decisions.
[ZH] 第二,他們發展了確例項子的方法,認識沒有一個証明的証明能完全解釋出一個小人的証明。
[ZH] 而他們加入了生理、心理、生理、社會、社會的証明,和環境的証明, 進入一個更新的解釋。
[ZH] 人際關係還有環境因素整合到他的個案件當中。
[ZH] 第三,他們建立了強化的療程關係。
[ZH] 知識很重要,證據的治療都很重要,
[ZH] 但無信心、聘用和合作,
[ZH] 甚至最好的接種方法都不可能會成功。
[ZH] 第三個一個非常有經驗的臨床人員的話
[ZH] 他會試著去發展深厚的治療與辦關係
[ZH] 雖然專業知識很重要
[ZH] 但是如果和個案之間缺乏信任關係
[ZH] 參與感和合作關係
[ZH] 再好的治療措施可能也沒辦法成功
[ZH] 四th, they developed individualized treatment plans
[ZH]  no two adolescents are exactly alike
[EN*]  If every treatment plan looks the same,
[EN*]  We should probably be questioning whether or not every assessment we have done is sufficient.
[EN*]  And finally, they measured outcomes.
[EN*]  Clinical excellence is not simply doing good work.
[ZH] 是要知道我們的工作是在幫助,這需要忠誠,需要繼續考慮,而且需要有信心去改變我們的方法,當進行不斷發展。
[ZH] 當我看著這五個角色,我看到有趣的東西,每一種都建立在前面。
[ZH] 可以知道我們的介入是否產生了實質的幫助
[ZH] 所以這個就需要謙虛持續的成效追蹤
[ZH] 然後呢如果今天進展不是很順利的話
[ZH] 我們願意隨時去調整我們的介入策略
[ZH] 那當我們把這五個這個臨床卓越的特質串聯起來的話
[ZH] 我們會發現其實這其實是環環相扣的
[ZH] 我們不能強迫我們的客人去工作,但我們可以影響他們的關係。
[ZH] 測試的效果幫助我們更加進行的效果,整個細節會成為我們做的基礎。
[ZH] 大家可以看一下同一篇。全方位的評估會帶來很精準的理解。
[ZH] 很精準的理解就會催化出個別化的治療,身後的關係會促進改變發生。
[ZH] 我們是沒有辦法強迫個案改變,可是我們如果跟他們的關係很好,它是可以發揮正向影響,那可衡量的成效會繼續引領我們繼續緊進,所以這五個歷程其實是緩緩相扣的,那也就構成了我們工作的基礎。
[ZH] 我學到最重要的一堂課是, 症狀難以解釋自己的情況。
[ZH] 幾個小孩們可能遵遇了抗承抗病毒, 但一是抗承抗病, 另一是抗承抗病毒, 另一是抗承抗病毒, 另一是抗承抗病毒, 另一是抗承抗病毒, 另一是抗承抗病毒, 另一是抗承抗病毒。
[ZH] 那我學到的最重要一堂課就是
[ZH] 其實症狀本身很少能自己去解釋他的成員
[ZH] 假設今天有好幾位青少年
[ZH] 他都可能符合重度憂鬱症的診斷標準
[ZH] 然後呢有一個孩子他憂鬱可能是因為他有創傷沒有去解決
[EN*]  treatment should not be for those. Clinical excellence requires more than
[EN*]  accurate diagnosis. It requires accurate case formulation. It requires us not
[EN]  only to ask what we see but why are we seeing it. That question changed the way
[EN]  our clinical team thinks about every adolescent that comes through T-VOS.
[EN]  Our team developed the clinical wheel as a practical case formulation framework
[EN]  drawing on established ideas from the biopsychosocial model, developmental
[EN]  and medical psychology, family systems, trauma informed care, and neuropsychology.
[EN]  That is the framework of the clinical wheel.
[ZH] 由於症但他們的介入和治療策略絕對不應該是一樣的
[ZH] 即使他們的臨床診斷是一樣的
[ZH] 所以臨床卓越需要超越單純的正確診斷
[ZH] 那還需要精準的這個個案概念化
[ZH] 那所以我們要問的問題不只是我們看到了什麼症狀
[ZH] 要去深究為什麼會有這些症狀
[ZH] 所以這樣子的一個提問方式就改變了我們TILOS團隊
[ZH] 看待每一位個案青少年的視角
[ZH] 我們會結合了生物心理社會模式
[ZH] 發展心理學
[ZH] 家庭系統理論
[ZH] 創商照顧以及神經心理學的理論來發展出這套講狗
[ZH] 就是剛剛給大家看的病創品
[ZH] 在我的職業生涯中,我的最大轉變發生在於,我不再只去問這個性上面他是有什麼病
[ZH] 我會去探討究竟是哪些原因的互動作用可以解釋這個青少年當前的適應功能的表現
[ZH] 這兩個問題看似相似,可是背後的思考合計是不一樣的
[EN]  It helps us communicate with other professionals, guides research, and conform treatment decisions.
[EN]  Diagnosis are valuable, and they are an essential part of the clinical practice.
[EN]  Diagnosis, however, rarely explains why one adolescent develops
[EN]  significant impairment while another adolescent with the same diagnosis
[EN]  functions quite well. It also does not explain why two adolescents with the same
[EN*]  diagnosis may require different, completely different treatment plans. This
[EN*]  is where case formulation becomes essential. Instead of asking what
[EN*]  disorder is present, we ask what factors have interacted over time to create the
[EN*]  difficulties we see today. That shift moves us from labeling a problem to
[EN*]  understanding the person. And I would suggest that understanding the person is where clinical
[EN*]  excellence begins.
[ZH] 另外一位卻可以大致維持良好的適應功能
[ZH] 那他也沒辦法解釋為什麼相同診斷的個案
[ZH] 需要完全不一樣的這個治療方案
[ZH] 這就是為什麼個案概念就是case formulation
[ZH] 不可或決的原因
[ZH] 那我們是要問說有哪些因素是互動影響
[ZH] 最終形成了我們今天看見的眼前個案的困境
[ZH] 所以這種思維方式呢
[ZH] 就不會是在給問題貼標籤
[ZH] 而是成為真正理解一個人的方法
[ZH] 那對我來說這才是真正卓越的決裝飾
[ZH] 當我們的團隊開始這樣思考的時候呢,我們就意識到我們要一套標準化架構來引導我們的貧富。
[ZH] 因為如果沒有架構的話每個專業人員會只去看自己熟悉的層面
[ZH] 比如說精神科醫生就會只關注精神狀況、患病的症狀
[ZH] 心理師就只關注創傷的部分
[ZH] 社工程就只關注家庭關係的部分
[ZH] 特教老師和陪伴的人員就只關注新聞的表現
[ZH] 其實每個視角都有它的價值
[ZH] 可是單一視角是沒有辦法看清全貌的
[ZH] 每個人的觀察是值得的,但其他人自然說整個故事
[ZH] 所以我們問我們如何保證每個年輕人能確定、體驗、實際上、個人的認識
[ZH] 這問題讓我們提供醫療的理論
[ZH] 所以我們剛才給大家看的臨床評估輪
[ZH] 就是要讓大家在評估每個孩子的時候可以獲得很全面、很一致的精準評估
[ZH] 而不是隻從單一視角來試圖去看清
[ZH] 可能會增加這個小孩的困難性。
[ZH] 還有對藥物的生理反應等等
[ZH] 所以我會問說哪些生理因素是在加劇這位青少年的脆弱性和防腦性
[ZH] 家庭的歷史經驗是一番最初的固定
[ZH] 如果有幾個家庭的人感受到瘋狂、瘋狂、抗瘋狂或病毒
[EN]  understand the adolescent risk profile. We also examine sleep carefully. Chronic
[EN]  sleep disruption can intensify depression, anxiety, impulsivity, and
[EN]  emotion dysregulation. Sometimes improving sleep produces meaningful
[EN]  clinical improvement before any psychotherapy techniques have been introduced. However, we will look at sleep in another area of the world as well.
[ZH] 或是其他病死的話
[ZH] 我們常常可以從中得到一些遺傳風險的線索
[ZH] 另外呢睡眠狀況很重要
[ZH] 長期的睡眠障礙會加具憂鬱、焦慮、衝動性還有情緒失調的症狀
[ZH] 所以有的時候其實還不用任何心理治療
[ZH] 只要光是改善個案的睡眠品質就可以帶來顯著的臨床改善
[ZH] 記憶體的重要部分是這個
[ZH] 科學影響效果的影響效果
[ZH] 但仍然解釋整個環境
[ZH] 在探討生理因素的時候
[ZH] 有一個核心原則就是
[ZH] 生理因素會深刻影響個案的功能表現
[ZH] 但是它很少能單獨代表權貌
[ZH] 第二項是我們稱為 hardwiring
[ZH] 這意味著身體原則自然取得
[ZH] 製作、擁有資訊和使用資訊
[ZH] 它包括理論性的問題,例如實驗、學習性的技術、工作的記憶、自動性的角色、智慧性的角色、智慧性的功能。
[ZH] 還有整體智力、認知功能
[ZH] 那腦神經結構這個領域呢
[ZH] 徹底改變了我看待青少年的方式
[ZH] 因為許多神經多上性的孩子
[ZH] 他們多年來會以為自己是一個很懶惰
[ZH] 然後很缺乏上精心
[ZH] 因為他們愛唱版標的人
[ZH] 那腦神經結構這個領域呢
[ZH] 徹底改變了我看待青少年的方式
[ZH] 因為許多神經多上性的孩子
[ZH] 他們多年來會以為自己是一個很懶惰
[ZH] 然後很缺乏上進行又很愛唱反標的人
[ZH] 但事實上他們其實是在一個跟他們大腦處理訊息方式
[ZH] 不相同的環境中在掙扎
[ZH] 所以理解神經構造會改變我們對這些孩子的期望
[ZH] 然後也會調整我們的介入方式
[ZH] 那最重要的是它會改變我們如何引導孩子看待自己
[ZH] 我們就不會再斥責他們說你為什麼不再努力一點
[ZH] 而是呢,我們轉而探討說,我們需要提供哪些輔助還有支援才可以讓你發揮出你的潛能,然後邁向成功
[EN*]  We look at the different subsets of the IQ scores around verbal comprehension, visual spatial, fluid reasoning, working memory and processing speed.
[EN*]  We look at the scores compared to the averages, and if there's gaps in between the different
[ZH] 我們會看數量相比,如果有不同的數量是不同的數量,
[ZH] 這可以提出問題像學習性疾病、
[ZH] 經濟疾病、學習性疾病、
[ZH] 硬度、社會性疾病、
[ZH] 壓力感染性疾病、
[ZH] 經濟感染性疾病。
[ZH] 我們會講到接下來的這個方法。
[ZH] 當我們在看這些智力測驗的分項指標的時候,
[ZH] 我們應該要深入分析各項指標之間分數上面,
[ZH] 如果說有一些專案他有一個很顯著的落差的話
[ZH] 他通常就可以指向了就是孩子可能遇到哪些障礙
[ZH] 比如說非語文學習障礙,訊息處理障礙,認知故作啊等等
[ZH] 就是那我們等一下會再詳細的分享因應的介入
[ZH] 第三個領域是後天行德行為
[ZH] 其實每一個後天行為的出現
[ZH] 都是在反映出當下的某一個問題
[ZH] 比如說逃避行為
[ZH] 是可以迅速降低內心的交流
[ZH]  anger creates distance
[ZH] 那如果就是有憤怒行為的話
[ZH] 其實個案可能是在建立一個安全距離
[ZH] 來保護自己
[ZH] perfectionism attempts to prevent failure
[EN*]  The substance use temporarily reduces emotional pain.
[EN*]  Overuse of technology and lack of sleep can show signs of ADHD.
[EN*]  These behaviors often begin as adaptive attempts to solve difficult problems, however, over
[EN]  time they become ineffective or even harmful.
[EN]  Rather than asking how do we eliminate this behavior, we first ask what need is this behavior
[EN]  Only then can we see or can we help the adolescents develop healthier skills that meet them the same way in these needs.
[EN]  To work through the section we use the erase and replace technique, we erase these maladaptive skills and replace them with adaptive skills.
[ZH] 內在的需求,為什麼會出現這個行為
[ZH] 那要看清這一點的話,我們才能陪伴孩子建立一個更健康、更正向的技能去取代那些原來不好的行為
[ZH] 去淘汰掉那些行為模式
[ZH] 第四專案是個人形狀
[ZH] 我代表個人形狀我代表是繼續思考、感受和與其他人相關的方法
[ZH] 這些不必是個人形狀
[ZH] 他們可能包括完美、硬性、疑惑、疑惑、和慕情的困難。
[ZH] 或是她會給人一種耍特權的感覺
[ZH] 或是她會沒什麼責任感
[EN*]  It's also not a good feeling.
[EN*]  Trauma, on the other hand, reflects experiences that overwhelm a young person's ability to cope, and they alter how they view themselves, other people, and the world.
[EN*]  Trauma for care here is essential.
[EN*]  One of the things we've learned is that trauma should neither be ignored, nor should it be used as an essential part of the trauma.
[ZH] 所以創傷知情照顧,就是TRAMA INFORMED CARE就變得很重要
[ZH] 但是我這邊也要提醒,就是我們不能忽視創傷的存在,但是也不能把創傷當作解釋所有臨床問題的藉口,就是一個卓越的臨床評估呢,是讓我們可以把創傷和其他領域的存在。
[ZH] 在做一個全面檢視,而不是說過度重視創傷的這一塊
[ZH] 最後一個領域是環境系統因素
[ZH] 沒有一個青少年是可以在完全孤立中成長的
[ZH] 所以家庭關係,手足互動,同償,學校,社群等等
[ZH] 這些都是會影響孩子的發展
[ZH] 環境有多重要,有時候我們很想要去改變這個孩子,但是外在環境不消除他就會持續強化,然後維持住那些我們試圖要減少的問題行為,所以環境很重要,我們臨床人員要隨時檢視說,在這個孩子現在身處的環境中有哪些是支援的力量,哪些是問題的來源,所以要達到穩定的成效,我們這個環境要做出哪些調整。
[ZH] 當我們把這六大領域整合在一起的時候,我們就會發現這個現象,就是每一個青少年的臨床病,
[ZH] 為什麼每一份的治療計劃都必須要量身打造
[ZH] 所以臨床主義並不是說給每個個案一套標準化的療法
[ZH] 而是要深入瞭解每一個孩子
[ZH] 如果他量身打造最適合的整合的架構
[ZH] 當我們知道整個人的治療計劃變得更明顯
[ZH] 科學指揮了醫療的考驗
[ZH] 睡眠的確定性和想法治療的管理
[EN*]  That when we look at the whole person, the treatment plan becomes much clearer.
[EN*]  If we look at the whole person, the treatment plan becomes much clearer.
[EN*]  If you look at this, we need to plan to ensure that your brain works well.
[EN*]  Hardwiring suggests executive functioning support, educational accommodations, and helping the adolescent understand how their brain works, and important skills development.
[ZH] 那如果從神經結構來看的話,也許我們可以匯入一些生活陪伴輔導,然後學校可以做出一些合理的教育調整,或是個別化的支援,並且很重要是要引導孩子接納自己的大腦運作特質。
[ZH] 在後天習的行為方面,我們可以教導孩子情緒調節,忍受挫折,然後適應,去用這個行為調整來取代逃避
[EN*]  Environmental factors highlighted the importance of family therapy.
[EN*]  school collaboration, and helping parents create consistency in the home.
[ZH] 單獨使用任何一個介入都不足以成功,我們必須把它整合成一個多角度的支援網路,
[ZH] 所以就不是指治療單一的症狀 而是把它當作一個完整的人
[ZH] 所以這就是治療診斷和看見全人的一個本質上的差異
[ZH] 不太多了。
[ZH] 所以要了解一個青少年並不是可以靠單一的臨床人員就做到的
[ZH] 沒有任何一個人不管他多有經驗可以自己看到全貌
[ZH] 治療師他可能只有在診斷期間會看到這個青少年
[ZH] 精神科醫生可能是把重點放在藥物治療上面
[ZH] 那直接跟這個孩子有最多時間相處的人
[ZH] 那他可能才是可以觀察到一些別人看不到的時刻
[ZH] 那就是為什麼在我們TILOS的這個計劃裡面
[ZH] 就是每一個青少年的每兩週都會有一個完整的治療團隊
[ZH] 去做下來討論然後會面然後調整計劃
[ZH] 那它並不是只有在入住機構的時候發生
[ZH] 那也不是只有在退就是回到原來生活的時候發生
[ZH] 而是每兩個禮拜就是隻要這孩子還在我們機構的話
[ZH] 我們就會有這樣的一個計劃
[ZH] 我們的團隊會包含了主要的治療人員
[ZH] 還有我們的 direct care
[ZH] 就是直接給予教護的人員
[ZH] 還有我們的學術團隊
[ZH] 還有家庭治療師
[ZH] 我們這些工作人員會一起梳理六個臨床輪的六大面向
[ZH] 我們會去評估生理上有什麼改變了
[ZH] 腦神經結構有什麼改變
[ZH] 行為上有什麼改變
[ZH] 環境上有什麼改變
[ZH] 我們對於青少年的瞭解
[ZH] 自從我們上次見面到現在又有哪些問題
[ZH] 一些幼稚聖都在我們的醫院了很多月份。
[ZH] 過去那時,有很多事情可以改變。
[ZH] 一個年輕人的固定和抑制可能會看不見四個月後,
[ZH] 但這種改變不少在一樣。
[ZH] 它會發生在小時的轉據,
[ZH] 這些轉據是容易失去如果沒有人看得很近,
[ZH] 而常常看得到。
[ZH] 每個星期的工程都會看得到很近,
[ZH] 那有一些我們機構的青少年
[ZH] 他會在我們機構大概上數個月
[ZH] 那在這段時間內
[ZH] 其實是可以有很大的改變去發生的
[ZH] 那比如說可能有一個青少年
[ZH] 他剛來到我們機構的時候
[ZH] 他是充滿防衛心的
[ZH] 但是四個月後他就完全不一樣
[ZH] 換一個人脫胎換個
[ZH] 但是這些改變並不是一觸可擊的
[ZH] 他都是積月的去產生影響
[ZH] 那而且這些微小的改變
[ZH] 最好的改變其實是很容易被迷失掉的
[ZH] 但是我們因為每兩個禮拜就會一起結合各領域的工作人員做下來好好地檢視
[ZH] 所以我們會確保我們老師非常密集而且很近距離在觀察理解的位置上臉
[ZH] 這也是 where humility becomes practice, rather than a simple idea.
[ZH] A therapist may believe treatment is progressing well.
[EN]  A direct care staff member may see things differently
[EN]  in the milieu of night.
[EN]  A teacher may notice something different in the classroom.
[EN]  While none of these observations alone
[EN]  are more correct than the others,
[EN]  but together they are more complete understanding
[EN]  of the child alone.
[EN]  Shifting or staffing adolescents every two weeks
[EN]  forces us to ask the questions we might otherwise avoid.
[EN]  Is our current treatment plan still the right treatment plan?
[ZH] 那一個這個直接照顧的人員
[ZH] 他卻可能在晚上有不同的觀察和發現
[ZH] 然後呢老師可能會在教室裡面不一樣的觀察
[ZH] 所以這些觀察都是正確的
[ZH] 每一個都是正確的
[ZH] 那他們必須被拼在一起湊在一起
[ZH] 才可以讓我們可以用更全面的角度
[ZH] 而不是去單一的片面的去觀察這個孩子
[ZH] 那所以我們每兩個禮拜
[ZH] 就會就是共同的工作人員
[ZH] 工作人員一起坐下來討論
[ZH] 然後會面就是在問這個問題
[ZH] 就是我們很容易會忽略說
[ZH] 現在的治療計劃還是在正確的方向嗎
[ZH] 那我們對於這個孩子的瞭解
[ZH] 是否有一些改變
[ZH] 那改變大到足以
[ZH] 我們必須去改變現在的計劃
[ZH] 現行的計劃需要做出調整
[ZH] 那這樣子的一個節奏就是
[ZH] 每兩禮拜會發生
[ZH] 每兩週的節奏可以確保我們的臨床輪持續的滾動
[ZH] 並不是孩子剛進來機構的時候只用一次而已
[ZH] 他是一個長期持續貫穿整個治療計劃的大原則
[ZH] 一組合作的職員會只能夠提供資訊的資訊,所以每個兩週的職員會集中,我們團隊會集中了一些訊息和測試,並非經常的評論,並非故事,並非說,如何我們覺得這週是進行的,是更加訊息,並非正確的訊息,並非我們在建立的專案,並非我們在建立的專案。
[ZH] 那這個我們剛剛講到每兩個禮拜一次的這個
[ZH] 大家員工聚集在一起的這個聚會要有效的話
[ZH] 條件是要有足夠的資訊帶進來
[ZH] 所以這就是為什麼就是每兩個禮拜一次的這個員工
[ZH] 就是會面發生前我們的團隊都會集合收集
[ZH] 就是一個非常具體的資訊還有方法
[ZH] 那這些資訊是必須和青少年的目標是緊緊相關的
[ZH] 所以並不是一個很概略的印象
[ZH] 也不是隻是講故事
[ZH] 然後也不是隻是單純的說
[ZH] 你今天覺得怎麼樣這樣子而已
[ZH] 我們必須確保我們收集到的資訊
[ZH] 都是非常具體
[ZH] 而且是可以量化的
[ZH] 而且是和我們幫青少年設立的目標
[ZH] 是緊緊相扣有關的資訊
[EN]  Those goals matter themselves a great deal.
[EN]  A vague goal, like improved mood or do better in school, cannot really be measured.
[EN]  And it cannot really guide treatment.
[EN]  Instead, we write each goal to its specific domain of the clinical will, and state it in a way that we can actually observe.
[EN]  Reduce the frequency of dysregulated episodes. Increase completion of academic assignments.
[EN]  Increase the number of family sessions where the adolescent engages openly, rather than shutting down.
[ZH] 比如說,我們要減少情緒失調的頻率
[ZH] 或是說我們要增加課業作業完成度
[ZH] 或是說我們要增加孩子在和家庭成員互動的時候
[ZH] 可以有更多的時間,而不是把他們自己關閉起來
[ZH] 這樣才是有效的資訊
[ZH]  skipped the next slide, but we're almost out of time, so we are out of time.
[EN*]  There's one final element that makes all of this possible.
[EN*]  Even the most accurate assessment has limited value if the adolescent does not trust the clinician.
[EN*]  Researcher across many treatment models has consistently shown that therapeutic relationship
[EN*]  is one of the strongest predictors of positive outcomes.
[EN*]  Our understanding tells us what to treat.
[EN*]  Our relationship determines whether treatment can occur.
[EN*]  Sorry, can you repeat this again?
[EN*]  Research across many treatments models has consistently shown
[EN*]  that therapeutic relationship is one of the...
[EN*]  Sorry.
[EN*]  There's one final element that makes all of this possible.
[EN*]  The most accurate assessment has limited value in the adolescent, if it does not trust the clinician.
[EN*]  Research across many treatment models has consistently shown that therapeutic relationship is one of the strong predictors of positive treatment.